today I'm going to talk about the real
reason why you are tired and I have a
lot of experience with this because I
personally have been
tired for years probably decades before
I figured this out and so part of the
body that generates energy is the
mitochondria those are those little
energy factories which is also a
fascinating Topic in itself because
these mitochondria have their own DNA
which is just fascinating and the theory
behind of how mitochondria evolved is
basically this bacteria cell that
invaded our body and didn't get digested
it formed a symbiotic relationship with
our own cells and now we give it a home
we feed it and it produces energy
because there's a lot of similarities
between mitochondria and bacteria and
also another similarity between
bacteria and the chloroplast the stuff
that has the the chlorophyll in plants
that harvestes the sun's energy it's
kind of like the plant's mitochondria so
our energy is generated from the
mitochondria and there's a very very
common reason why the mitochondria might
not produce the energy I mean even if
you give it the right Fuel and that has
everything to do with a very key
nutrient called thymine or B1 which
really is the spark plug of the
mitochondria B1 is the essential very
important uh helper vitamin to help you
convert
fuel into energy not just to fuel energy
but to power all the different systems
in the body now I have a very good demo
just to help you understand what B1 does
okay because in a car motor you have to
have fuel and oxygen right but you also
need a spark plug if you don't have a
spark plug nothing's going to work in
this demonstration I'm going to use a
roadside flare okay and I'm going to
blow gasoline on this flame okay as you
can see right here I blow gasoline onto
the flame and it will help the flame get
brighter and of course I didn't use
gasoline I used cornstarch right so
don't try this at home and basically
this represents B1 is the spark plug to
allow this fuel to be burned in this
next part I want to demonstrate what it
would be like without B1 okay you can
see I have the fuel being blown on the
flame but basic nothing happens in fact
it goes out okay that would be running
your body without B1 okay so we have
these mitochondria right and there's all
these biochemical Pathways that occur
and you need various things you need
fuel
and I'm talking about not just glucose
or carbs I'm talking about protein as
well as fats okay so B1 is necessary to
turn all three of those into energy and
give you your metabolism to run the
different systems of the body now
certain parts of the body have higher
amounts of mitochondria than others like
for example your heart has the most
mitochondria in the muscle and so if you
were to be deficient to be one your
heart would suffer and so and then
what's going to happen you might have
arrhythmias you might have an increased
pulse rate to compensate you may have
cardiac failure you may have all these
issues and then we have the brain which
also uses a lot of mitochondria certain
parts of the brain anything that
requires a lot of oxygen okay and fuel
so if you're deficient in B1 you're
going to get brain fog you're going to
have problems with your mood you're
going to have a lot of neurological
agitation and so you're going to feel
stress
more you're going to feel nervous energy
built up especially because B1 really
helps power the nervous system and
another big part of the nervous system
is the autonomic nervous system okay
that includes both the flutter fight
which is the sympathetic part of the
nervous system
as well as the parasympathetic which has
to do with rest and digest so let's just
talk about the parasympathetic first you
have something called Sleep pressure so
it's an active thing that is pushing you
into the deep sleep cycles right well
that requires B1 sleep is not a passive
thing it's an active thing where your
body has to be put into so you can rest
and repair so B1 is very very necessary
to go through all the different sleep
cycles and if you don't have enough B1
you'll have all sorts of sleep problems
from sleep apnea to a uh getting up at
two o'clock in the morning to nightmares
especially to having vivid dreams to
just getting up and feeling crappy now
let's talk about digestion so if you
don't have enough B1 you're not going to
have the pumping action of the colon
peristalsis which relates to
constipation you can also increase your
susceptibility of getting something
called small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth now as far as how B1 affects
the sympathetic nervous system this is
really really interesting because it
will basically keep you in a flight or
flight mode okay so it's going to be
really hard to recover from uh stress
and so a person that's deficient in B is
going to be very reactive they can get
angry very easily and B1 will just
totally put the fire out and calm them
down and give them a sense of relief
this also relates to tolerance to other
types of stress like cold intolerance
now this also relates in a recent video
that I talked about taking cold showers
people that can't tolerate a cold shower
are usually deficient in B1 and so they
get into this cold and boy they just
they just can't tolerate that and the
same goes with intolerance for heat they
can't tolerate being outside in high
Heats they just their bodies just like
shut down so if you're deficient in B1
any little stress will affect the person
person a lot more and so if you can't
tolerate being stuck in traffic for like
hours at a time or maybe babysitting a
lot of small kids you know at a daycare
center you may be deficient in be one
and that is my dry sense of humor if
you're deficient of B1 not only are you
going to be tired but there's going to
be a lot of other problems that can
occur like your fluid backing up as
edema I already mentioned high pulse
rate if it's very severe you might have
a condition called pots and without kind
of getting into the details of what that
is it's a situation where you have a
difficult time even standing up and you
get dizzy and there's all sorts of
problems so pots is a very severe B1
deficiency so even like if you were to
get up very quickly and feel dizzy that
is a classic inability to tolerate
gravity stress and that usually is a B1
deficiency and especially going upstairs
or of incline where your legs feel
heavier
pink B1 deficiency shortness of breath
is another symptom
hypersensitivity for certain odors might
be a B1 deficiency and anything related
to recovery okay so let's say you
exercise you just can't recover and
you're an athlete and you have poor
recovery think B1 and the B1 deficiency
can also Express itself as many other
conditions too like peripheral
neuropathy if someone's a diabetic they
have numbness in the bottom of the feed
or burning sensation That's a classic B
deficiency because B1 also helps build
the myelin sheath as well that's a whole
different function B1 deficiencies can
also be a huge dent into your immune
system okay the mitochondria within the
immune system can get damaged and so you
have a poor immune system and especially
recovery after an infection if a person
is B1 deficient they're going to have a
heck of a Time recovering from any virus
as well as certain vaccines that can
damage the mitochondria I put a link
down below but I can't really talk about
it too much but you'll be able to read
up on how a vaccine can deplete B1 and
affect someone's mitochondria and to
give them all sorts of residual side
effects that are related to the
mitochondria so those are some of the
symptoms of the B1 deficiency but I want
to just touch on certain conditions that
set a person up for needing more B1 okay
now the more carbohydrates and
especially sugar that a person consumes
the more B1 that is needed so they can't
just get by on a little bit of V1 they
need a lot of B1 to be able to
compensate for the demand for B1 if
you're on a medications the requirement
for B1 goes way up especially
antidepressants and to anxiety
medication antibiotics diuretics
metformin and there's a lot of other
medications so let's say for example you
just don't have a lot of energy and
you're eating good but you're on a
medication or maybe two or three or four
or more and you have all sorts of other
issues and doctor can't figure out
what's going on well you probably are
just so depleted to be one that nothing
can work so you're not going to feel
good and what they're going to do is
start giving you more medications to fix
this and that without understanding
where it's really coming from the more
overweight you are the more diabetes you
have the more other health problems you
have chronic inflammation the more B1
you're going to require and also if you
have any infection whatsoever the
requirement for B1 goes way up as well
the more alcohol you drink the more B1
you're going to need unfortunately
medical doctors you know may check for a
B1 deficiency if you have a late stage
alcoholic situation other than that they
don't usually look at B1 and if they do
find a B1 deficiency they'll look in the
blood but they're not really
understanding the demand that is
increased with all these other
situations so your demand is not just
about hitting the you know Bare Bones
rdas you need a lot more the more
insulin resistance you have the more B1
you're going to need and I'd say
majority of the population has insulin
resistance now people that have
allergies or some type of sickness from
mold or mildew or some chronic you know
infection with viruses whatever
really need a lot of B1 because you have
this revved up immune system that's
constantly sucking up all the B1 that
they have people with uh digestive
problems need more B1 because some of
your microbes make B1 and then pathogens
are going to compete for that last
little bit of B1 that you have and so
leaving you high and dry now I mentioned
some conditions that deplete your B1 but
there's also other things that can
deplete your B1 the big one is that tea
and coffee and red wine so the more tea
coffee red wine a person has the less B1
they're going to have of course the more
sugar they have refined sugar the more
B1 they're going to need and so there
are things that are like anti-thymene or
anti-b1 alcohol would be considered one
metformin which is for diabetes sulfites
in wine as well as in dried fruit and as
a preservative it can deplete your B1
raw fish like sushi can actually deplete
your B1 as well unripened fruit can
create a B1 deficiency caffeine can
create a deficiency and stress also
sucks the B1 out of your cells and so
does seed oils seed oils like the corn
oil soy oil canola interfere with the
enzymes to allow B1 to be transported
and so with me the reason why I had such
fatigue for decades was because I was
consuming the refined carbohydrates not
to mention alcohol not to mention a ton
of coffee and just sucked all the B1 I
how to make and I wish I would have
known back then what I know now because
it's so simple once you understand the
importance of thymine and also how
thymine gets depleted and by putting the
bee back in and correcting the
underlying Clause you can get your
energy back now to be totally
transparent I do sell a natural B1
product okay but I don't recommend
buying that product unless you fix the
underlying costs and I'm talking about
your diet you're talking about some of
these other things that we mentioned and
start consuming food that's high in B1
so I'm going to give you a few things
that have high levels to be one okay
number one animal meats and the one that
has the most believe it or not is pork
and if you need pork I would recommend
consuming a high quality healthy type
pork salmon and other fish have a good
source of B1 sunflower seeds has B1
acorn squash eggs have B1 and
nutritional yeast has a good source of
B1 of course if you're going to get
nutritional I would recommend getting
the source that is not fortified with
the synthetic version of B1 and so
anytime you take B1 don't go for the
synthetic go for the natural now I did a
very in-depth
um I think extremely interesting
presentation at one of my keto Summits
okay and I want to put that up right
here because it totally covers
everything you'd ever want to know and
need to know about vitamin B1 check it
out I put it right here